the anti-recruiter recruiter right
people often asked me why do I have the
anti-recruiter recruiter strap guard I
kind of feel like the industry's broken
it needs fixing service levels and
recruitment are bad customer service the
canvas service levels are bad I think
the reputation of recruit is bad because
for me it was well how am I going to
differentiate myself how am I going to
do something different I will say to my
guys now do lots of everything don't do
a small amount of one thing do lots of
everything you cannot forget you have to
work on what you put into this is what
you get out of this welcome back to
another episode of the recruitment
mentors podcast I'm your host his and on
this week's episode I was joined by Tom
Wood Tom has worked in the industry for
over two decades and over the last three
and a bit years he's been building his
own recruitment business Evans denim
group Tom is not afraid to share what he
thinks he's honest and I absolutely love
that when I meet people who are nothing
short of themselves and are authentic I
think it's really important in today's
world to be exactly that so we talk
about everything from Tom's Korean
recruitment The Good the Bad the Ugly
his entrepreneurial Journey so far what
he's learned the difficulties and also
why he likes to call himself the
anti-recruiter recruiter and we dive
into that so plenty to learn think you
enjoy it I think you'll be inspired
enjoy the conversation welcome to the
podcast thanks for having me
thanks for making the trip I've um as I
said to you when I reached out to you
enjoy your videos enjoy your content
yeah
uh not uh what's the word not scared to
share your opinion yeah be yourself yeah
and I always respect that about people
so I'm I'm really excited to yeah dive
into this journey of yours what you've
learned the challenges
um and most importantly talk about this
uh entrepreneurial Journey that you're
on after building a successful career
and recruitment so I'm gonna ask you the
the million pound question that we
always like to start with but I guess
what I always like to do just for people
listening is
just offer people just some immediate
context on where Tom is on his journey
what he's been up to and then yeah feel
free to add in the thing so
um how long have you been in recruitment
I'll say 20 years yeah um
I think give or take yeah 20 years okay
two decades of recruitment yeah okay
cool and then I'm feeling it
and then obviously just to add the the
sort of um in the last couple years
context and what we're going to be
talking about so you officially launched
your own recruitment business in Jan
2020 correct right
um and what so as yourself your wife is
also a shareholder and then one of the
very early employees that join you on
the journey is also shareholdering that
business right so your whole background
uh was Tech sales correct right so you
did that for yeah over 10 years 15 years
but I know now um in your
um over the over the last couple of
years it's become sales and digital you
have a holding company and I know
there's a few different things that
you're really excited about coaching
training these types of things that
we're definitely gonna talk about but in
terms of the first year of your business
journey I think you shared with me that
you ended the first year around like
eight to ten people yeah I think
um in terms of Revenue in and around the
million pound Mark yeah I think that was
mainly all perm correct you said at that
point and then obviously going into the
second year you was aware that you
definitely wanted to build more of a
contract part of your business
so this is where in the second year um
you invested in the digital team correct
yeah
um and then yeah I think second you said
it ended around 14 people
um near around the 1.5 million Revenue
marks third year
just over 2 million rev yep and the
contract split now of is around 20
contract eight percent perm around 18
people but then we've got people in
marketing Finance customer success not
just uh recruiters correct and then as
you so you're now in your fourth year
just started just died so January now is
the sort of our fourth year fourth year
okay cool perfect so hopefully that
helps people listening yeah that's where
you're on your business yeah but I guess
why don't we start with it with this
question which I'm sure you've fought
long and hard about there's one thing
hiring recruiters for your team when
you're employed yep it's a whole nother
thing home recruiters for your own
business
so I'd love to hear Thomas thoughts on
yeah in your opinion what
characteristics and traits do you
believe make up a highly successful
recruiter in today's market yeah good
question
um so
for me the the the typical recruiter
um has probably changed since I started
you know
um when I started out in the boiler room
when I started out doing the three hours
a day on the phone kpis you know beat
you with a stick to work that person was
very different to the person that you
now see as a successful recruiter
um and that's a good thing I think the
characteristics have changed what I do
think though is that some of the
fundamental disciplines are still there
so some of the fundamental
um process structures disciplines still
need to be there you know we've become
social we've become social selling
but that still doesn't mean you can't
have activity you can't have structure
you can't have effort you can't have
work so I think for me I look at I look
at do I want the stereotypical wide boy
no I don't
um but do I want some of the traits that
those people had historically absolutely
I do so if I think about some of the
people I've hired and some of the people
that become successful recruiters for me
they haven't come from recruitment so
I've hired personal trainers for example
so a couple of guys I've met in the gym
from from being mates going to the gym
on a social level
and I I would look at those guys and
I've hired them in my previous companies
and that kind of person
the reason I would hire them is because
they are so structured if you think
about anybody that does weight training
at a decent level
they track their food they track their
diet they track their macros they've got
training plans they've got food plans
they've got prep time they wake up at
five o'clock in the morning to prep
their meal they go to the gym at six
o'clock they have a second meal they're
if they're doing PT they're doing their
day planning they've got
um a plan throughout the day of set
appointments they're structured they're
processed they follow programs they're
competitive because they want to beat
the person in the gym next and it's
lifting more to them there's an element
of ego there's an element of material
things that want to look good
um all of the disciplines the
competitiveness the structure the
process the organization all of those
disciplines are transferable not just to
recruitment but to sales so I would say
to those guys look you do that either
for your personal gain or for your PT
business transfer that into recruitment
and you would be a success and it's and
it's proved you know those guys have
come in they're the ones that have the
day plans they're the ones that are
doing homework at night they're in early
they're gyming in the morning they're in
the office at eight o'clock you know
nine o'clock for anybody else they're
structured they're processed they
they're disciplined they're competitive
they want to beat everybody they want to
win everything
that for me is is some of the core
skills that I think make a good
recruiter I think if you're not
competitive if you're not structured if
you're not process driven you will
struggle you know but it isn't it isn't
the
um the levels of perhaps what it was in
the 90s when I started or late 90s you
know it's a it's a different version of
that but some of the fundamentals do
still apply yeah and I like the way that
you've put that in terms of the mix of
yes some of the disciplines and the
important stuff
is still true today absolutely yeah and
I I really like that so
just to touch on your career then
um I think a couple of things I just
wanted to dive into straight away if
it's cool with you is when we're sort of
preparing for this so you've always
typically been in like a perm
recruitment environment right
um or not yeah to a degree so I have
done a contract I've I've built contract
desks I've built contract businesses but
the bulk of my experience would be more
perm and it has it for a long time was
it Tech sales always tick uh yeah I mean
always Tech and then I'll say for the
last 15 years Tech sales Tech sales okay
cool so um what I'd love to ask you is
one of the things that you said to me in
preparing for this which was around
um you was in a position at that time in
your career where consistently you were
billing Circa 500k yeah yeah now for a
lot of people that would be a
destination they'll dream of getting to
yeah right so I want to just sort of
dive straight into there in terms of
like what does Tom think he had to do
consistently well yeah to get to that
point right because I think a lot of
people be interested in that so I guess
a question to ask you then just to start
to unpack that I'd love to just get your
thoughts on Tom early days what was he
doing differently compared to Tom at the
latter end of his crew when he was
consistently billing 400k or whatever a
year what was he doing differently that
meant you were getting way different
results like compared to early on to
when you were doing later on what were
some of the fundamental things you were
doing differently the yeah you had to
learn the hardware that enabled you to
get better results do you think yeah
good question I think
um and again I look at I look at that
question question probably from the view
of recruitment but also generally in
life and I think I've I've learned those
things and applied them to life as well
um I think when you're younger and
you're inexperienced you do you kind of
have this scattergun approach
um and it's a scattergun approach where
you just do anything you know you do
anything and again I put that into life
you do anything in life you know
um and I think in recruitment certainly
sales that was my Approach I was always
a good salesperson I was a natural
salesperson my parents would say to me
I'll either be after daily you know
selling used cars and hustling or a Dell
boy or I'll be Richard Branson
um you know it's kind of one one extreme
to the other and and for a long time I
was the Dell boy you know because I was
kind of hustling I was doing whatever
always had ideas always had different
business ideas
um but never really stuck at one thing
and I think if I think about recruitment
you know I fell into recruitment which
which I touched on with you I think
towards the end
um it was never a destination I wanted
to be
um and for me it was one of those yeah
I'll do it I'll give it a go see what
happens
and by doing it that way and not having
that focus and not having that view of
I'm going to make this work you do it
and you hustle and you beg you borrow
your steal you kind of you know you do
whatever you have to do to do deals and
that's kind of what I was doing so so
there wasn't any thought process to it
there wasn't any structure to it in the
early days it was simply I'm a good
salesperson I can black it I'll do this
but this isn't my job this isn't my
career I'm going to be a professional
football player I'm going to be you know
whatever
um so you hustle when you wing it and
you do whatever you can to get by
and and then what happened I think for
me was probably two or three years into
it not being my job it became my job
um and and I was good at it you know and
people would say you're good at this you
know and and my winging and my kind of
hustling was actually becoming more
repetitive and more consistent where
actually it was now becoming well that
is my process and that's what I do
um and then over the years you refine it
a bit and over the years as you say you
make mistakes things don't work you
learn from those things and and I think
over a period of time you then start to
recognize
that this is working you know you start
to go this is actually like this is
this this is this is proving
um and as it proves and as it becomes
more consistent you refine it more you
focus on the things that do work you you
realize that actually if things aren't
working you fail quickly and you learn
from that and you and you apply
different approaches to things and I
think for me that's where my career
certainly recruitment went it was a case
of winging it and hustling and not
really caring suddenly going this
actually works refining learning
adjusting the biggest thing I I would
say for me is that I've been adaptable
in recruitment so so I was one of the
suppose um
this was one of the first recruits on
LinkedIn but when LinkedIn hit the
market in 2008 I think it was
um I was on it you know and I saw the
value in it and I saw the um the
potential of it
um so I quickly I quickly took that on
board and that was in a period when it's
still very much database three hours a
day on the phone
um X many dials a day suddenly there was
this social platform and and that was
hard then because if you've seen on
LinkedIn the day you were getting a
kicking you know your boss was giving
you a kicking they've been on LinkedIn
but it was kind of in my mind I'm going
but this makes sense and I quickly
adapted to that and I quickly adapted to
this whole social selling concept
um so I think being adaptable has helped
me but definitely having structure
process routine consistency refinement
failing quickly learning from my
failings and improving and keep going
that's what I've done throughout my
career to where I am now where it's
become muscle memory it's become habit
it's become routine it's become I know
to do that stuff because I've done it a
million times
um but I see a lot of people that don't
do that a lot of people don't stick to
things they they fail and bail which is
a good saying that I typically use
um they they don't learn from mistakes
in which case they keep making the same
mistakes again and again and again which
is another thing I see regularly a
definition of insanity keep doing the
same thing again and again again
expecting a different result
um so lots of people don't do that and
for me that's where I've always been
good is I've I've seen what doesn't work
and I've changed it I've done something
different I always say to my guys now do
lots of everything don't do a small
amount of one thing do lots of
everything yeah there is a numbers game
to this and if something doesn't work
stop doing it do something else so I
think having that mentality has really
served me well and that's enabled me to
do what I do it's got me where I am and
now I'm at a point where I'm still doing
those things I'm still making mistakes
I'm still having massive errors but I'm
learning quickly but some of the
fundamentals of recruitment have become
habit they've become muscle memory so
one or two just one or two things on
this really quickly
I honestly Tom people love a day plan
mate when people people listen to this
so you said there how important a
structure process being disciplined is
yeah so can we just because it was
probably different now but could we just
very quickly before we then talk about
your sort of entrepreneurial Journey
cost yourself back to when Tom was doing
the biggest numbers yep
um what was his day plan people want the
detail me honestly people love this you
want the real answer or do you want me
to give you a yeah nice let's keep going
let's keep it real mate so the real
answer is I had no day plan okay I I was
drunk you know I talked about this I had
an alcohol problem and when I was at my
peak of recruitment I was drunk you know
I was I was a functioning alcoholic so I
was
um you know I was traveling the country
I was I was I was working uh the big
systems integrators I was I was up in
Bradford I was in uh Norwich I was in
Reading I was supporting some big big
software projects I was out with the
program managers the project managers
the pmo managers I was I was going for
lunches and so I that was a period in my
life when I didn't have that structure
okay because I was I was living the
dream I was building 500 Grand a year I
had a team of resources working for me
so I didn't have I would say the
um the set structure that you would you
would expect to do those numbers what I
did have though was a structure that
built up to that level you know so there
was things I did repetitively and
consistently that got me to that level
um you know I didn't go and pick up
those clients and win those clients and
those relationships by chance there was
a method to my madness that got me to
that level and that was that was you
know simple things like in the morning
you check your emails first thing and
I've always been a morning person you
know even when I was in my drinking days
you know I would I would get up at six
o'clock you know I would work 24 7. not
because I was told to but I just enjoyed
that mentality you know I was answering
emails at four o'clock in the morning
whilst feeding my youngest you know
feeding them a bottle of milk whilst you
know middle of the night
um so I've always had that kind of off
the cuff reactive kind of uh mentality
anyway and I would always do something
uh uh just whenever I needed to I wasn't
nine until five but always check my
emails in the morning always kind of you
know what needs reacting what needs
focusing on okay then you start to
structure your day I'd never do BD at
eight o'clock in the morning I'd never
do be at nine o'clock in the morning you
know I'd be at be there say 11 to 1
o'clock for example afternoons a
difficult time for BD people have lunch
they're a little bit sluggish you start
hitting them with BD calls it doesn't go
well so I would I would put those
structures in place
um you know in projects on LinkedIn
would be done the night before so you
get a response overnight so you've got
calls to make the next day those kind of
things I would do
um but yeah when I was building my big
numbers I was I was you know traveling
around the country whining dining
entertaining which is still a massive
skill
um and people don't do those things as
much anymore
um and that was largely what what
enabled me to do the big numbers and I
had a team and everything else now I
appreciate it being honest and I know we
wanted to speak about this or you
mentioned this because I saw saw your
um video that you put up I don't know if
it was yesterday this week on that dried
January yeah yeah I think I made a note
the what I think you did you say that
you've been like 12 years sober probably
more yeah 12 to 13 years now I've kind
of lost track of it it's kind of lost
its importance to me in terms of time
frame because it's just become a thing
yeah become a thing let's just talk
about this for a second because I think
it'd be helpful I feel like it could be
its own podcast itself but let's talk
about you very kindly kept it real there
and was honest yeah yeah so um I think
what I personally would be really
curious about is let's be honest the
journey that you've been on
um you can apply to the things that
you've obviously had to learn and work
through to then I guess move away from a
habit that obviously wasn't serving you
yeah can be applied to a lot of
different habits right for people
listening so it doesn't necessarily this
is only relatable to you if you have a
drinking problem or you have a bad
relationship drinking right which is so
for me I guess the thing that I'd be
curious about was firstly when when did
Tom look in the mirror and think and
start feeling that he had a I don't know
a toxic relation with alcohol because I
don't know I feel like from all the
things that I listen to and uh I don't
know I feel like there's there must have
been a period where you sort of the
story you told yourself was like this is
fine it's part of the job one and dining
I'm making this money so yeah I don't
know if there was a moment or it built
up over time but why don't we start
there and then maybe you can talk about
some of the things that you've had to
learn the hard way and that might be
really helpful for people so I think I
think the alcohol thing for me was was
was it recruitment was it before
recruitment it probably was before
recruitment if I'm honest um and I think
the in the video I did recently I'll
talk about the two the two um different
alcoholics you've got the one that
suppresses a problem so you drink to
self-medicate and then you've got the
one that actually alcohol is a chemical
problem and you create a trigger in your
body which is the
um
uh the craving mechanism so the minute
you have wandering people talk about oh
I've opened the floodgates now yeah yeah
you have one drink I needed 100 because
my craving kicked in and I couldn't stop
that craving and I'm a pretty stubborn
guy I couldn't stop that craving so I
had that problem I wasn't suppressing a
problem I wasn't suppressing a you know
trauma I had a craving so that was
always there
um and perhaps it increased over time
and as I got older and drank more but
perhaps it became more prominent um so
maybe that was an aspect of it and going
into recruitment back in the you know
the late 90s early 2000s you know that
was a period when it was cocaine it was
booze it was you know especially in
London
um so maybe that contributed to it but
it wasn't the it wasn't the defining
Factor
um but I think look you know for me
recruitment probably exposed my
insecurities and frailties
um so I've always had imposter syndrome
when I was playing football when I was
selling cars I've always thought I'm
going to get found out I'm not that good
so I've always suffered still do suffer
from that it's a big thing that
is in my head now today last night you
know it's constantly there and I've got
to use it to drive myself now and it
channels me or I Channel it and it
drives me I should say
um so I've always had that and an
alcohol would be something that I would
I would use perhaps to to stop my brain
stop my insecurities stop my anxieties
I've been in anxiety sufferer for years
um so I think alcohol was something that
actually it started to kind of
um
suppress some of those things and and
and hide some of those things but also
it contribute to some of those things
because the thing of alcohol is actually
when you have alcohol your depression
goes up your anxiety goes up your
insecurities do go up they might go for
a minute but they come back a lot worse
so for me it was I was seeing this
increased
kind of feelings of of stuff I didn't
like and and I always had this vision of
who I was I'm going to be successful I'm
going to be entrepreneurial I'm going to
be a strong person that everyone goes to
I'm going to be the cool guy you know
that was always the kind of person I
wanted to be the Brad Pitt the George
Clooney that was always what I wanted to
be
but with the alcohol I was going the
other way I was turning into the
liability I was turning into the lunatic
that everyone didn't want to go out with
I was telling into the mess in the
corner so my my journey of trying to be
this person I wanted to be I was going
the other direction and I think that was
the point to answer your question when I
suddenly went this is up I'm I'm
not I'm kind of on this destination of
who I want to be I'm going backwards I'm
turning into the bum on the street that
people are laughing at and I think that
was the point for me when I suddenly
went this isn't this isn't working and
then when I had my kids it kind of
became the big thing I didn't want my
kids to see me as that person I didn't
want my kids to see this
um person that just you know they were
ashamed of they're embarrassed you know
to be around so for me that was it I was
like right I'm done and and the funny
thing is when you stop drinking unless
you really want to stop drinking you
can't stop drinking and so for me for
six months eight months a year before
that I couldn't stop drinking because I
didn't really want to I was like yeah
it's fine I'm enjoying it you know I'm
cool when I'm drunk you know but but at
the point when you suddenly go this is
you know that's when you know
you're going to stop and I stopped
haven't touched it since don't want to
touch it don't need it
um and and you know what the person that
I want to be I don't think I'm there
yeah I'm not saying I'm this cool yeah
yeah but I'm on that Journey yeah I'm on
that Journey no I appreciate you sharing
that I guess just really quickly then
um what what would you say if if I'm
listening to this right now and it could
be alcohol it could be drugs it could be
just like I said a really you're aware
of a habit that isn't yes you isn't sort
of serving your future self yeah what
like what would be your advice for
someone to take how can we take that
first step you know of I think you've
got a direction I think you've got to
accept and realize there's a there's a
problem um and look you know when I talk
about these things like you say it could
be alcohol could be drugs could be you
work too much could be
uh your work-life balance is wrong it
could be
um you know I see lots of people now
when they they stop drinking they're a
place they're drinking with something
else it could be the gym it could be
whatever if you if you find that you're
doing something to the excess
um and it's affecting the balances of
everything else in your life you've got
a problem um so I talk about the pillars
of my life I've typically got three
pillars I've got the gym I've got work
I've got my family and if you think
about
um a kind of a Greek Coliseum you know
the pillars going up they're my pillars
and on the top of the the pillars you've
got a platform
if one of my pillars is slightly
say higher than the other you've got a
slanted platform so you imagine me or a
ball on that platform the ball starts
rolling that ball represents your life
it represents who you are if my pillars
are slightly off then I've got an
imbalance yeah
um so the ball my life is going to slip
away I need my pillows to be level I
need my my work my gym my family to be
level and I've kind of created that it
all kind of interacts it intertwines and
it's got a nice balance
sometimes however I go the wrong way
sometimes I go right work work
work and family suffers I don't see my
kids I'm not reading bedtime stories I'm
not spending time with them I'm not
present they feel it and I feel it and
it starts to suffer then I'm going
I need to see my family more so I'll
stop going to the gym for me the gym is
a mental thing as well as a physical
thing so if I'm not going to the gym I'm
getting stressed I'm getting anxious so
I can feel it because I'm stressed and
anxious my kids are getting neglected my
work is suffering it's all it's all gone
to ship so for me I've got to have that
balance and I've got to have that
Harmony and that's my advice to anybody
that if they're doing something to the
excess if it's affecting other aspects
of your life you've got a problem if
it's not and your life is great and your
life is brilliant and everything's fine
and you're not being a and you're
not you know hugely in debt and you're
not getting in fights and you're not
cheating on your missus or your
boyfriend your work's brilliant
everyone's happy
fine crack on really because you you
know there isn't a problem yeah um but I
think if if for me the rule of fun
really is if you're doing something to
excess that's affecting everything else
in your life or even one aspect of your
life you need to address it yeah and
it's having that self-realization lots
of people will tell you something's
wrong
but until you realize that you've got
the right there yourself yeah until you
realize it yourself you won't change it
no it's a really yeah you can really
visualize that one where you sort of
said that it's a really good way to look
at that so let let's talk about this
entrepreneurial Journey that you're on
then yeah um why don't we start I think
an always great place to start is sort
of how Tom thought about how he's going
to make his recruitment business
different
um maybe we can maybe it could be part
of it but maybe we could start with I
know it's like one of the most engaged
pieces of content you've done the
anti-recruiter recruiter right and I
think your video is around why do I have
this strap line like why is it important
to me we don't have to start there but I
want to talk about it but how how was
Tom thinking about making his
recruitment different how are you yeah
what was your differentiator let's start
there and then we'll we'll break down
this journey yeah so I mean look I
anybody that's willing recruitment at
some point in their life goes I'm going
to do it for myself you know you kind of
have that internal conversation lots of
people don't do it because it's a risk
lots of people think no I'm not going to
bother and they're earning big money
um for me it was always in the back of
my mind and I so I should have done it I
could have done it years ago I shouldn't
have done it years ago because I wasn't
ready
um when I did it was at the right time
because I was ready I'd run businesses
I've built businesses I'd you know I'd
managed hired fired so I was ready 10
years ago I wouldn't have been ready
um so for me when I did it it had to be
how am I going to make this work because
there's so many bloody recruitment
companies there's so many recruiters
there's so many friends in the sheds
there's so many people in their bedroom
doing recruitment so and I didn't want
to be that you know and I used to have
battles with my wife about this because
she would go no you know do a lifestyle
business we'd go on loads of holidays
and and for me I was like that's cool
but I want more than that I want to make
a difference I want to do something I
want to be impactful I want to be
remembered I want to do something that's
going to have some kind of a legacy I
don't just want to be Tom at home going
on loads of holidays which I could have
done build half a million quids lived a
brilliant life but I wanted more than
that
um so when I looked at Recruitment and
I've had this frustration with
recruitment for many many years
I generally don't like a lot of the
industry I don't like a lot of the
people in the industry I don't like the
um how the industry is conducted I don't
like the the some of the practices as I
talk about the wide boys I don't like
that mentality I don't like the sort of
the Pinstripe suits the red braces the
the brown loafers that you know I can't
stand that
um and I think I think there is an issue
with that and I think recruitment
companies and recruitment owners drive
that behavior and I know why they do it
you know they it thinks they think it
makes the money to a degree it might do
but that's a short-term win for me
um you see all these guys spouting off
The Wolf of Wall Street you
know and you know if your wife's ugly
get on the phone and it's just like
Jesus Christ and I've seen people do it
yeah so I kind of feel like the
industry's broken it needs fixing I
think the uh the service levels in
recruitment are bad I think the customer
service the candidate service levels are
bad I think the reputation of recruiters
is bad so there's there's lots in there
that needs fixing so for me it was well
how am I going to differentiate myself
how am I going to do something different
how am I going to make an impact the
anti-recruiter stratman wasn't the kind
of the the outset goal the outset goal
was we're going to do this better the
initial thing I was going to do better
was be a better recruitment company for
my employees that was the thing right
um so I came from a recruitment company
that was quite hardcore
um you know mobile phone in your draw uh
the CEO would
um would track how long you're in the
toilet for you know you'd get an email
going you spent seven minutes in the
toilet what were you doing you know it's
like do you really want to know
um you know your mobile phone's in your
drawer you weren't allowed to go and
talk to people you know so so for me it
was like I'm going to make this a better
environment for my employees I'm going
to make it a you know a better life
work-life balance so and you know what
it pissed me off actually because
pre-covid I was kind of one of the first
recruitment companies that went remote
working unlimited holiday relaxed
environment no kpis were going to be
you're going to take ownership you're
going to be accountable we're going to
hire adults I'm going to treat like an
adult you know what you're putting is
what you get out that was my whole
Vision covid came along and completely
stole my thunder over came along
and literally was like the whole
world of it remote so I'm like got
to get a new USP
um and and we're kind of doing that and
we're kind of evolving with that
actually the funny thing is I've
slightly reverted on that now because
I'm not a big fan of the fully remote
model which is what I preach at the
beginning because I've seen it doesn't
work you need to have
um a hybrid element you need to have the
the people the competitiveness the
culture so I've kind of reverted a bit
but initially that was my setup this is
what we're going to do this is how we're
going to be different the evolution of
that is we can do that and that's cool
but as I said kind of covert came along
and pissed on the bonfire a little bit
so I've kind of lost what made me
different what I'm sort of now doing is
going you know what actually I'm going
to make more of an impact than that yes
we've got a lovely company yes we can
have our values and who we are and I
still stand by that but I'm going to try
and impact the industry more you know I
am going to try and fix the service
levels I am going to try and uh Whittle
out the ship recruiters I am going to
try and reduce the amount of bad
recruiters bad habits bad behaviors so
I'm on a I'm on a journey
um to massively change that industry
um and it's the perception of the
industry
um from a from a candidate perspective
from a client perspective from the
externals looking in I'm on a journey to
change that and some of the things I'm
doing from a business perspective will
will impact that and we'll change that
and there's some stuff we're going to
launch this year that will do that
um you know does it need to be regulated
possibly
um because essentially look you could
you could you know meet a guy tomorrow
and still in the dream of recruitment he
goes yeah brilliant I'm gonna
set a business up goes and sets it up
starts recruiting for people what he's
been essentially doing is he's affecting
the company he's recruiting for he's
affecting the person he's recruiting
isn't got a clue and that's the problem
with recruitment you can affect the a
business and you can affect someone's
lives by selling them the dream but
completely misleading them and then
you've knackered a business you've
knackered someone's life because you've
sold them the wrong dream and that for
me is a worry because nothing's
regulating that Nothing is Stopping that
from happening and that's where I think
recruitment's got an issue but but so
you know I'm going to try and fix that
I'm going I'm on a mission I'm on a kind
of a
some kind of a I don't know a journey to
try and change that industry and and
what I want to be is that there's
credible recruiters left because there's
so many of them out there but they get
tarnished with that bad brush hey
everyone a real quick one from me this
podcast would not be possible without
our amazing podcast Partners Vin cherry
and Source breaker because you listen to
this podcast you were able to get your
hands on exclusive savings on both of
these award-winning products if you're a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincere who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with Source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
Source breaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products well
why don't you just talk really quickly
on that because look I think when we
spoke about this look that that really
resonates for me it's a big part of I
started this podcast and for me
personally I don't know what you how you
feel about this but I think we've got a
better chance of getting to the place
you're describing if we collaborate more
rather than um tear each other down 100
but I think what I liked when you even
in this video but it's what you said to
me as well is yes 100 the industry has
to take accountability for some of the
things you said but it isn't it's also
obviously you would you shared me around
your perspective on well part of the
accountability as well is clients and
absolutely and encouraging bad practice
so why don't you just talk a bit just
share your perspective on that because I
think that's that would have been a big
reason why people really enjoyed that
video is like yes there are a lot of
people that cut Corners do rubbish
things but also it can't the
accountability can't just be on
um recruit yourself what was interesting
well and it is for me because it's very
easy to blame recruiters yeah very easy
but recruiters are only reacting to a to
a to a situation they're they're
reacting or responding to an environment
or they're reacting responding to a
situation now for me there's
accountability across all three
components of recruitment candidate
client recruiter there's accountability
there it's a bit like the chicken and
egg where did it start and there'll
always be an argument on that you know
to say no it's them it's you you know
for me when I look at it I think there's
accountability across all it so let's
think about the the recruitment Journey
typically I'm not talking about
exclusivity I'm not talking about
retained I'm talking about conventional
speculative permanent recruitment which
is the majority of the industry so so a
client has a role a client goes right
need to fill this role Mega urgent let's
get it out there let's get it in the
market right let's go and hit all the
all the usual suspects so they go and
pick six recruitment companies you know
they go right we're gonna do this
they're um they go to market is right
we're gonna have one briefing call
um you can't ask any questions on that
call you can you can listen you can
maybe send an email through uh following
that call you can't have any contact
UM you're going to send all your CVS
through the applicant tracking system
um and we'll come back to you you know
when we've reviewed them when we feel
that there's there's a good profile
um so they're basically going right
we're going to handcuff you so you can't
do this you can't do that you can't do
this
plus you're going to race against six
people
um we're not going to pay you a penny
up front we're going to pay you nothing
but we're going to let you race we're
going to let you go essentially the
winner is the one that gets their
quickest that's the winner the winner is
the one that gets their quickest so so
what will typically happen and and
recruitment model is those six agencies
will go right hell right let's
run Let's Race let's right we've
got to beat these guys we've got to go
and and what you're then doing is as a
recruiter you're going well I haven't
got time to be credible I haven't got
time to do the research I haven't got
time to
um spend on a pitch I haven't got time
to spend on a nice presentation I
haven't got time to really qualify
people properly because I know I'm
racing against those six guys and I know
some of those six guys and they're going
to be ruthless so so you're racing
you're sacrificing quality you're
sacrificing substance you're sacrificing
credibility
and what's going to happen is you're
going to lie you're going to cheat
you're going to manipulate you're going
to cut Corners you're going to try and
shaft your mate you're going to try and
and do whatever you can to win that race
so so what then is happening is CVS are
getting sent without being qualified CVS
are being sent about the candidate even
knowing you know all these bad behaviors
are coming into it because it's a race
and then the clients go oh it's amazing
got all these CVS they start
interviewing the candidates the
candidates are rubbish there may be one
that gets through the loop and they kind
of go yeah okay we're going to hire that
person that person then leaves after two
months
what then happens is the client turns
around and goes to the recruitment
company that was terrible that was a
service you know you were awful but
what they don't realize is they started
that mechanism they started that
mechanism by basically saying you can't
do this you can't do that it's a race
off you go first one to get to the
Finish Line wins they've started that
behavior the candidate will also be
accountable because the candidates
sometimes will lie the candidate will
cheat the candidate will play recruiters
off against each other to get there to
get their best way or to get their the
way they want it um you've got all this
kind of manipulation and lying going on
within this process because that's what
people do people are selfish people are
greedy people will
um will do what's right for them so
you've got you've got the recruiters
being skeptical of the candidates the
can that's been skeptical of the
recruiter the client has basically
created this race that no one's going to
win in because it's going to be an
absolute show
um and that's the recruitment process
but the one that will get the blame for
that will be the recruitment company
yeah and everyone turn around and go
well that was Bloody wasn't it you
know so for me it's like that is that is
where the breakdown comes in and that's
where it needs to be be fixed
recruitment should be retained
recruitment should be you should even do
it as like so in the tech industry
you'll have a an RFP for example or an
RFI so a request for information a
request for pricing you pick some
companies you let them tender so create
a presentation and tell me why you
should get this wreck or you should have
six months of exclusivity with us they
present they pitch you choose that
person off you go it becomes a proper
partner you would see a massive uptake
in the in the recruitment process if
that was how it was done yeah
so talk to me about this business
Journey then so what's been most
difficult so far people yeah without a
doubt give me some color to that like
what what people talk about people are
the the biggest frustration I think in
business but definitely in recruitment
because unfortunately in recruitment
you're dealing with people
um people for me has been the biggest
challenge what have you been my surprise
by
with so if I think about my business you
know Evans denim group the biggest thing
for me is is trying to do right
um but I think whenever you try and do
right you're still perceived to be doing
wrong
um and that could be candidates that can
be clients in some cases employees you
know employees don't necessarily think
you're trying to do right by them
um so I think people is the hardest
challenge that I've seen on this journey
trying to keep everybody happy trying to
do what's right by people
um trying to
um
create an environment where everybody's
happy because that's hard
um does it exist I don't know
um is there ever a company where
everyone's happy I don't know but that's
been a that's been a challenge
um and then I think let's say you you
look at the aspect there of clients of
people candidates of people employees
are people the whole concept of this
business is people
um so that's definitely the biggest
challenge yeah what about specifically
hiring because that does I'll be honest
that whenever I sit down with
recruitments that really does end up
being something that they get really
right or have to go through a lot of
pain to get it right
um what what's been your journey with
that like what have you had to learn the
hard way when it comes to actually
hiring for your own business so I think
I think we've kind of got it right we
haven't had a huge attrition
um in in the three years we've been
running we've had some steady growth
we've lost some people
um
but I would say they were obvious errors
um so I hired my nephew
um young lad 19 at the time a little bit
lost wanted to give him a direction
wanted to give him a
um a journey
um it was never a business benefit you
know it was never uh something that was
going to grow the business I was trying
to help him
um and in hindsight should I have done
that I don't know would I do it again I
probably would
um but that didn't work and that was
obvious
um another guy I hired was a former
employee uh I think he lost his love of
recruitment at his former company
um and he admitted that and I saw that
and they probably saw that I then
thought well I can reignite that
um again in hindsight could I did I know
I probably couldn't probably but I
wanted to give him a chance so again
this is that failing quickly thing you
kind of recognize your failings and
admit them you know
um generally we've been okay you know I
think where it becomes harder is to get
good people you know get the good people
get the credible people and especially
post covid because some of the things
that I could chuck out there pre-covered
when I launch the business they were
attractive points I could go unlimited
holiday I could go remote working Flex
visible you know no micromanagement fun
you know they were the things that I was
using to attract people and people in
recruitment that was non-existent
postcovid everyone's chucking that out
so so what is your differentiator you
know oh you know we've got 30 percent
um commission so is everyone uh you know
we do hybrid working well so does
everyone you know we do dress down so
does everyone so so there is no
differentiator right now it has to be
and this is kind of where I'm now trying
to do it has to be about the person or
the people they have to see that you are
the differentiator and that's they want
to work for that person
so curious then
um I think we spoke a bit about uh this
how how have you gone about building
um
leaders in your business or how have you
gone about yeah I guess making Tom
redundant or Tom not sort of involved
and in touch with everything because
that would have been the the only way
that you would uh yeah grown to over 10
going towards uh 20 people like what's
that Journey being like for you because
I know again that's really difficult
yeah really hard
um especially it's your own business
because you you just you're on it you're
on everything you're proud of everything
you're worried about everything
um it's hard
um I'm on that Journey now
um so I'm definitely not not finished
with that journey and and people that
will listen to this that work for me
will be laughing going he's
nowhere near finished on that Journey
um so I I'm you know what have I done
and have I done it I want people to be
leaders I want people to step up I want
people to have responsibility I want
them to have a sense of ownership so if
I think about Jake and George who work
for me who've built the digital practice
that's exactly what they've done they've
taken a sense of ownership they've taken
pride in what they do they're invested
in it to the point where they they
helped um our website builder build a
website you know everything is branded
to their to their colors their choice
I've stepped away from that completely
gone it's yours you do it
um and I can see the benefit of that
because they're so invested in it and
they're so proud of it
um trying to replicate that across the
business in other areas is not as easy
and I think that's because I might say
well I've got this sales Division I want
you to own that sales division it's
still not their division whereas Jake
and George came to me and we're going to
build this and I went great don't do it
so from the start it was theirs so I
think that does help
um I think giving people autonomy giving
people the ability to make decisions is
really key one of the things I would say
that I've done well is I've separate
myself from operations so I was running
everything sales operations everything
I've I've put Stacey my wife she's
running operations I've got my
sister-in-law Sasha she runs HR and
finance I've been lucky enough that our
developer guy has now joined us on a
permanent basis these marketing and
development so he's marketing director
I've got some amazing people that I
actually completely trust I've recently
hired a sales leader which I'm going to
be announcing this week or next week
something that's worked for me
previously so he's going to run sales
for me so I'm going to run the business
and all the other projects he's going to
run sales I've got my marketing director
I've got my finance and HR Director I've
got Stacy now as CEO so she's overseeing
operations so for me it's it's give them
the power and the ability but also hire
the right people you know I've always
been a believer of higher good people
and let them be good and that's hard
sometimes because being in the control
freak I am I want to meddle
um not as in a physical Med around my
neck because I want to meddle in their
effects and probably do on the middle as
well but
um but hire good people and let them be
good and actually
you notice it because some people you
hire that you think are good and they're
not good and you have to step in them
what I also say to all my guys is if I
have to step in and do something before
you do it you know you're doing it wrong
if you do something before I step in
you're doing something right
and I'm seeing that from some of those
now they're doing things before I even
say it they're doing things before I
even mention it and that for me is an
indication it's working so how have you
then worked out where Tom can have the
biggest impact on the business then if
all of a sudden you walk in the office
you're like I'm not needed what
have I got to do yeah you must have
figured out the right way energy and
effort there was an ego thing with that
and I've struggled with that recently
because I I want to walk in the room and
you know I I have an impact and they're
hinged on me doing something which is
mental because that's just you shouldn't
that'd be really common for sure but you
shouldn't have that
um but the ego in me is like why why
they're not waiting for me why are they
doing stuff and you know but that's
actually brilliant because they
should be doing stuff
um so where where am I so running the
business you know so I where I was
struggling back in the last year was I
was I was dipping into some of the other
projects that we're going to launch
we're going to build focusing my
attention into them and then forgetting
about sales forgetting about the
consultants and then what was happening
was numbers were dipping
um so I would then go oh right
forget about those projects I now need
to go and kick everyone up the ass and
get them back focused on on the basics
of recruitment which I would do and
numbers will go back up
um and then I'll go okay it's cool
numbers are back up okay I'll go back
and do those projects again and then
same again numbers would dip and you
know so so for me now it's like right
I'm going to run the business I'm going
to make sure that marketing HR Finance
is the absolute best it can be we're
going to have the best systems the best
processes uh from a marketing
perspective there's so much to do and I
love marketing
um so we're doing we're gonna do
podcasts there's a book coming out
there's various different businesses
we're launching we've got the Evans
denim group page which we're massively
driving the the brand and the following
on that we're at 250 000 followers in
three years uh we're going to get that
to a million uh probably in the next 18
months
um and that and that million becomes my
audience then I can then leverage for
all the other ideas I've got and all the
other
um things we're going to implement so I
can focus on marketing I can focus on
running the business properly
profitability is a big thing this year
we we haven't focused on profitability
that much so big focus of mine is
profitability not just on reducing cost
getting them getting the most out of but
yeah get getting the most out of what
we've got you know and driving the right
behaviors and maximizing those
um we've got the Hub which is my one of
my coach coaching platforms which is a
video content which we're going to
enhance we're going to start doing CV
resume LinkedIn reviews so I'm seeing at
the minute people are paying crazy money
for people to do professional CV writing
which is ridiculous someone quoted me
700 the other day that they're they're
paying
um so we're going to do some kind of an
AI uh CV LinkedIn review on the Hub uh
we're going to get other people on there
to talk about you know hiring tips so
where I've seen my mind shift a little
bit now is yes I'm in Recruitment and
it's Tech recruitment
um I'm actually looking at it going I
can actually have a bigger impact than
that you know if I think about the
masses out there the masses of the
people that are looking for work I've
reached the the realization how people
don't know how to get a job people don't
know how to interview correctly people
don't know how to write CV people don't
know how to close how to pre-close they
don't know how to get engagement they
don't know how to interview the
interviewer they don't know how to
ensure they lock in a second stage they
don't know this stuff
um so I'm I'm on a mission now to to
help the people that are looking for
work help the unemployed by teaching
them those tools so I've kind of got
that side of my business which is more
of a generalized coaching then I've got
the recruitment business the model I've
got which is the evidence denim group
that's a parent company a holding
company that's where the infrastructure
of our business sits my vision is the
recruitment side can keep on growing you
know we could have Evans denim
Healthcare Evans denim construction
Evans denim
Finance for example so we'll have those
businesses in recruitment we've got
we've got Ed sales we've got Ed digital
we've got an internal business at the
minute which is Ed Tech it's not
external it could be
um I think it will go under digital if
I'm honest so we've got that business
um the other side of the business is
more coaching platforms academies I'm
going to build
um The Hub uh the book I'm going to
write and launch podcast we're going to
put out there and a lot of that is aimed
more at helping people to get hired so
it's not specific to Tech and
recruitment as such it's more about the
job market hiring unemployment how to
get a job
um and that for me is where there's a
massive value there's a massive value in
that and then we've got the app business
as well which actually is recruitment so
that sits on more on that side and that
will launch hopefully excuse me this
year as well
family yep talks about that you've you
work with uh you start this business
with your partner in life yep I didn't
realize obviously your sister and Laura
is part of that as well yeah what's that
been like I'm sure there's been
challenges with that yeah or something
like do you know what
Division and I had this vision and I
talked about my nephew hired
um my vision was to help people so I I
I've always said I don't want to be the
richest guy in the room I want everybody
to have some kind of a wealth
realization I want to change people's
lives I want to help people
um and that some people might call that
naive but that is who I am you know I'm
one of those guys it's always nice to be
nice yes I'm opinionated and yes I'm a
bit stubborn but it's always nice to be
nice I will always help someone I'll
walk down the street if I see someone
needs help I'll help them
um so for me it was like you know what I
want to help people
um you start with your family you know
my sister-in-law bless her she was
working part-time because she had kids
um the companies you worked for you know
it was an office job it was hard she was
getting paid
Pro router nine grand a year 15 grand a
year I think in the end maximum barely
living you know hadn't been a holiday in
abroad in God knows how many years
um and she's brilliant you know and I
love her to death and she works hard and
she deserves more
um so for me I was like I want to help
her so I bought her in she worked in
finance and she's done HR and so I was
like this is she could be my operations
manager bought Irene and and changed her
life and
I don't want plaudits for that at all
the plot it's I get is seeing her going
on holiday last year so I think they
went to Barbados or Cyprus her and her
kids and her husband you know that's
what I love seeing you know seeing her
you know being able to buy things that
she couldn't buy and live the life that
for me is just
I don't need her to ever say thank you
and I wouldn't ever want to say thank
you but that for me is I love seeing
that and to know that I've helped her do
that for me that's brilliant so that's
great
um she pisses me off and and I piss her
off and you know she's the first one to
ignore my WhatsApp so you know midnight
on a Saturday night when I'm moaning
about the p l
um I think she even mutes my my
notifications I think but but you know
and we've had a few chats and a few
conversations I've always said to a lot
I love you to death like don't ever
forget that you've got a job for life
but you piss me off but we have to have
that relationship my wife
um major issues when we first started
out she wanted the lifestyle business
um I didn't I wanted you know the bigger
business I wanted the Empire
um huge strain in the early days because
of stress because of the business
um was was absorbing me
um our relationship was failing my
relationship with my kids was failing so
a massive amounts of strain then
um we we changed the structure
um and she is now involved when we first
started out she was a shareholder
because it was just more tax convenient
you know it was more beneficial to kind
of go well you could have a salary and
I'll have a salary you can do a bit of
office management as your job and it
will kind of work
um and that was kind of how we
positioned she was a hairdresser for 16
17 maybe 20 years um so she wasn't in
recruitment so she's never worked in an
office so it just kind of didn't make
sense
we then made a decision that okay
I'm not gonna not do this because this
for me is my dream as a kid this for me
was my ambition was to build a business
so you know the only way that it's going
to work is if you actually have a proper
job in this you know if you properly do
something so I said right I'm going to
make new operations manager at a time I
think operations director and this is
going to be your job and you know what
she's been unbelievable like
unbelievable I mean learn a lot she
um she watches a lot she's she runs that
business as I do
um she can't do the things I do she's
not maybe got the ideas I've got and
she's not got the entrepreneurial side
that I've got and she's not got the
maybe the people aspect and maybe the
gravitation is very introverted you know
if she was sitting here now she'd be
under the desk probably crying you know
so she hasn't got that ability but she
is organized she's structured she is
where I'm perhaps too nice she's not
that nice and she'll she'll be harder
um she runs that business you know
phenomenally to to I mean you know and
and I sort of joke about it she ensures
the bloody coffee is filled up you know
she'll build a desk with me when a desk
needs building you know we're in there
we're building desks we're building
chairs we're putting TVs on the wall you
know we're that hands on
um so she'll do that stuff equally
she'll sit in marketing meetings Finance
meetings she runs the finance and
operations team now we've got a customer
success manager reporting to her she's
on it you know
um I've seen her looking at the p l more
than I do you know so she's on it
um so so to to have that I think has
been really fortunate because initially
it didn't work you know it didn't work
and it was the kids were suffering the
business was suffering the relationship
was suffering the extended family was
suffering my sister-in was her sister
that was suffering
um so to get it where we've got it too
is is much better
just as we come to an end and just on
that because I think a lot of people
struggle with this um
yeah I I think a lot of people when they
start their own business
do you actually ever switch off I don't
think so I just think you have to get I
what I've really had to get better at is
just being present
um I think there's nothing more worse
than your partner send like you're
you're not there or like that that's
horrible to hear so I'll get just on
that really quickly like obviously as
you kind of shared with us it wasn't it
was difficult like what what's ended up
really working if you ended up putting
some like good boundaries in place if
you ended up sort of putting some
non-negotiables in place it goes back to
probably where I talk about my three
pillars yeah
so my three pillars for me to operate
have to work in Harmony and I think
everybody has those but some people
might have 25 pillars
um again you have to kind of do some
your own self-analysis on this to work
out what the important things to you for
me it's simple it's it's my family it's
the gym and it's work
um but I don't have a an off switch on
those and I think that's what enables me
to work so I don't have a no it's family
time I don't have that that wouldn't
work for me
um I would struggle with that because
I'd have one eye so in the corner
looking at my phone going it was that
notification you know
um it has to be
combined so when I go on holiday I do
work but I go to the beach and I I play
in the pool with the kids and I might go
oh hang on a minute I'll be let me just
go and do a quick phone call and I'll
come back so I don't have what people
would have sometimes which is okay I'm
gonna do four hours of play time with
the kids and I'm gonna do three hours of
work I don't do that because for me
that's
that's really hard to manage and I still
think you're losing out somewhere there
and it's too rigid it's too structured
in in the the running of business and
the entrepreneurial world you can't be
that rigid you have to react you have to
be spontaneous but on the flip side of
that is I then have to put the phone
down and play with my kids I don't have
to put the phone down and go and play
football I have to go and you know do a
cannonball in the pool and you know for
me that works
um and and as a family that works you
know I have to go to the gym I go to the
gym it's on our it's on our business
park so I go to the gym in the morning
at nine o'clock I take the kids to
school I go to the gym at nine o'clock
I'm in the office at ten we start at 10.
um
I've done that I've got the balance you
know and then we'll go home and we'll go
home at five o'clock I'll play some
PlayStation with my kids my phone will
be next to me I'll go like mate I've got
going to talk this out now I'll go and
do a quick phone call I might get on the
laptop then I'll go back and play
Playstation again
um I'll play or in the summer I play
football you know we've got a big golf
net in the garden we're going to hit
some golf balls my phone's never not
with me so if it does ring oh hang on
mate let me answer this quickly and I'll
answer it um so for me it's uh it's a
kind of an intertwining process
um and that that isn't for everyone
you've got to find what works because
some people having the switch off and
the discipline works for me it doesn't
um if I have a switch off it increases
my anxiety muscle leaks I think what am
I missing so I have to have an
intertwining thing but I mean example my
kids after school they come to the
office
really yeah we've got Xboxes we've got
arcade machines we've got TVs in every
bloody room we've got three big offices
um they're going to play Xbox you know
we've got we've got drink we've got
sweets we've got donuts Krispy creams on
the go they love it you know my and it's
good as well because my kids especially
my youngest when we started this
business he was
three and a half he's now seven seven
and a half the people that work for me
Scott who who's one of the investors
he's seen my kids grow up he's like
Uncle Scott you know they're fighting in
the office they're you know so we don't
have that switch off and that is what
enables it to work for us the kids can
come in they play
um they mess about with the guys in the
office
um my daughter who's the oldest she
might on a Friday night if she's out
intriguing with her mates
she'll have a key to the office we'll go
yeah go back and get some pizza and go
and watch Tilly in the office yeah why
not no I appreciate you being honest
there because look I'm sure like there's
definitely a narrative online that
that's like oh no you can't do that it's
like work-life balance I appreciate you
being honestly it's what works for you
it's about what works for you then it's
what works I I we're not talking about
the alcohol thing the other day you can
only listen to what I say and and take
Snippets of advice it isn't the gospel
you know what works for me may not work
for you so you have to find what works
if you have to have an off switch and
you have to have a complete you know
turn your phone off at nine o'clock you
know people's about sleep and that kind
of thing and not having the UV lights
and all those kind of things if it works
for you do it if it doesn't don't do it
um
do I mean I don't think you should you
should follow set rules because someone
says they're the set rules yeah find
what works for you and if it works keep
doing it as I said before fail quickly
and learn from it apply that to life and
you won't go wrong
so look as we come to an end here then
I'd love to just end on here then what
What's um what's Tom's perspective on
what do great recruiters have to do in
2023 to yeah have a great year stand out
um I don't know how you feel about it
but for sure uh things are going to be
difficult for different people different
markets but yeah what what sort of
Thomas perspective and uh your Mantra uh
for this year and what people can do to
yeah just be successful do well yeah so
I mean without upsetting some of your
audience I think I think the generation
Zed
um
need to have a bit of a wake-up call
um because I think
where they want everything to be
um happy harmonious you know work-life
balance you know my mental health must
be amazing all those things which are
great
you cannot forget you have to work hard
and I think where I'm talking about the
generation Zed now because that's the
generation just behind me
very closely just behind me I'm just I
mean I just missed it I think I was a
millennial
um the generation Zed
they they have a different view
different perspective they need to make
sure they still work hard and a lot of
recruiters fall into the Generation Z
bracket they need to work hard you
cannot succeed if you don't work hard
you cannot be successful if you don't
work hard so my biggest Focus for
everybody right now is you need to work
hard you know think about the return on
investment what you put into this is
what you'll get out of this so if you
work hard you will do well there is a
numbers game to this when when gets
hard you have to increase the numbers so
you know I always talk about do lots of
everything don't do a small amount of
one thing you can get to a point where
you're you're billing 300 Grand a year
and you kind of got a couple of clients
and you you know it's going well you're
probably not applying yourself as much
as you would have done to build up to
that point you're probably into a
routine
if you lose two of those clients and
you're suddenly down to billing 100
Grand a year you can't sit back and go
it's all right it'll change and and rest
on your lot rules you have to go back to
what you did to get those clients and to
get that position you have to do a lot
of everything so work hard you know you
cannot sacrifice that work hard
put variety into what you do do a lot of
everything and be consistent the biggest
thing for me is consistency people do
something for a week and go that didn't
work and I'll do that again it's too
short or they do it for a day and go oh
I didn't get any results on that
you have to be consistent so I think the
three things I would say to anybody now
that wants to be successful work hard
don't ever ever sacrifice that number
two do lots of everything have variety
so mix it up and be consistent you do
those three things in Recruitment and
you will be successful categorically
even if it's a numbers game you'll be
successful yeah and just to add my
thoughts on that why people listening
should feel
um
freed by that or almost like that should
be a real positive is that all those
things that you just said there are in
your control massively and yeah we can
all get caught up in today and focus on
the things we can't control right and I
think the the sooner you start going
this I read this on the news so my
clients said this and all this is
happening you're going to be in trouble
so all those things there that Tom was
just broken down you can control and
that should donate that should give you
positive that should give you optimism
that if you control those things and
you're honest with yourself then you're
always gonna have a fight I think and
the thing the thing on that as well and
this is one of the things I would say to
anybody listening to this is we've all
got the same amount of hours in a day
and it's what you do with those hours
and it's how you utilize those animals
we'll determine how successful you are
you know you look at people that are
hugely successful they don't have more
time they just use that time better and
that's something else I think recruiters
need to realize you know we're not
saying it's nine till five
you can do nine till five but you'll
only get so far or you can do nine till
five but your utilization of that nine
to five is so unbelievable you just
Excel that's hard
but think about the 24 hours you've got
think about the time you're sitting on
your ass at home on the on the sofa
watching Kim Kardashian you know or
you're scrolling through social media
for four hours at home do something else
do something productive do something
that is gonna make you some money you
know I always say to people and I got
consumed by Instagram in lockdown I was
so self-obsessed with my six-pack and so
self-obsessed with just me being an
influencer and all that Madness I was
spending more time on Instagram than
LinkedIn and that was the year I should
be building my business it was mental
you know I was so consumed of it until I
had an epiphany I went what the am
I doing I'm on Instagram all I'm on
LinkedIn for what for likes for
validation that I'm I'm you know I'm fit
or whatever you know mental so I got rid
of it completely deleted it and I
focused on LinkedIn because that would
make me money you know your brand your
your putting your profile out there it
will make you money you're not going to
become an influencer on Instagram as
much as you might think you are you're
not do something's going to make your
money be productive you know maximize 24
hours you've got in the day you know
work hard do lots of everything be
consistent you will be successful
look Tom
um always appreciate people that I meet
that are unapologetically themselves and
I think that's exactly what you are and
I've always got time for people like
that and I think um yeah I think one of
the best things you can be in life is
authentic and I think that's that's what
you've been in this conversation spoken
about life mindset business
um but yeah like yeah I think you've
been on a great journey excited to see
from outside looking in the things you
clearly have big aspirations big goals
So yeah thank you so much for joining us
I appreciate it
I talk too much I waffle too much I
could sit here for four days talking so
I'm kind of I try to condense it so that
I'm not you know boring everyone but no
I really enjoy it and and like you know
I I see what you're doing and I see the
people you've got on there and to be
Associated to that is is really humbling
so I really appreciate it Tom appreciate
it thank you man thank you mate thank
you so much for listening to the episode
I hope you enjoyed it and got value from
the conversation if you did enjoy it
please don't forget to like share and
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
episode